as one of the six original Avengers
Scarlett Johansson has been playing
Black Widow otherwise known as Natasha
Romanoff for the better part of a decade
but being one of the fittest horses in
the MCU didn't come easily at all
Scarlett Johansson made her MCU debut
back in 2010 when she first portrayed
Black Widow and Iron Man 2 since then
she's had to maintain a high level of
fitness following the release of
Avengers endgame in April 2009 teen her
personal trainer Eric Johnson told The
Hollywood Reporter Scarlett always wants
to be within three weeks out of her peak
condition of course she's taken on
plenty of other physically demanding
roles outside of the Marvel Universe
like her roles in Lucy and ghost in the
shell' as she told a news getting
herself in fighting shape for ghost in
the shell' was no walk in the park going
to the gym eating clean and working a
long day and then going to bed and
sleeping well and getting up and doing
it again the next day
even though Johansson was a total
stranger to the gym when she was cast as
Black Widow and it sounds like they're
old friends now as she told The
Hollywood Reporter the gift of Fitness
has been one of the best parts about
working for Marvel I'm stronger and more
capable now than I was ten years ago so
how did she go from being a total noob
to getting totally ripped as her trainer
Erik Johnson points out Black Widow is
no ordinary role we're trying to create
this crazy comic-book hero in real life
with someone who's normal
the workout routine is truly
extraordinary let's see if you think you
can handle it the actress has been
training with Johnson since 2009 but
working out didn't necessarily come
naturally to her in 2019 Johnson told
The Hollywood Reporter that her first
rope climb was something of a disaster
on the way up she kneed me in the face
and gave me a nice bloody nose she was
celebrating and I'm fighting back tears
gushing blood but she learned quick
Johansson was reportedly way more
confident by the time she filmed the
Avengers according to Hollywood stunt
woman Heidi moneymaker incidentally
Heidi's sister Renee is also a stunt
woman
yes that is our real last name we were
born with it
in 2012 Heidi told shape magazine
Johansson is one of my favorite
actresses I have ever worked with she
works very hard and picks things up
really fast Scarlett Johansson developed
a great relationship with Heidi
moneymaker right off the bat
strictly speaking moneymaker was hired
to do things Johansson couldn't and
wouldn't do but in the end moneymaker
taught the actress that she could do a
lot of the stunts herself Heidi was like
my beacon of hope because she like lit
the way and she was incredible
Heidi is so creative and her movement
and all the movements really tell a
story when the pair reconvened for 2012
The Avengers they took their working
relationship to the next level and
squeezed in sneaky workout sessions
between takes with hand hand combat and
weapons training on the agenda it was
still hard work moneymaker told shape
Scarlett is such a professional and
works incredibly hard so she learned all
her fights and performed them with
perfect execution the words bodybuilding
and veganism don't usually go
hand-in-hand but more people are
discovering just how beneficial the diet
can be while training including Thor
actor Chris Hemsworth the stacked Aussie
star went vegan while training for
2012's The Avengers and so did Johansson
well almost
according to Johansson's former trainer
Bobby Strom the actress was on a quote
mostly vegan diet at the time in an
interview with E karate Johansson
quipped after lots of fighting and
training and raw vegan food you can fit
into a cat suit she ate lots of kale as
she tried to get fit for the first
Avengers film but when the shoot was
done so was the vegan diet she confessed
the Fox News buffalo chicken wings I am
addicted to them
Scarlett Johansson's next appearances
Black Widow came in 2014's Captain
America the Winter Soldier starring
alongside super-ripped actor Chris Evans
is likely to make even the most
confident performer feel inadequate
but Johansson clearly rose to the
challenge talking to Elle in 2013 she
revealed I like lifting weights and
doing exercises to work my core muscles
to be honest I work out like a guy it's
this heavy focus on weight lifting
paired with her strict diet that gets
Johansson where she needs to be
Johansson told Access Hollywood
it's boring 5 a.m. workouts and salad
and chicken and nothing
pretty much it's that old tried-and-true
workout like a dude and eat like a
rabbit Johanssen also followed that
routine when it was time to get in shape
for 2015's Avengers age of Ultron we
picked up the same program we'd used for
Iron Man 2 and it had a proven history
Scarlett Johansson took a rather extreme
approach to training for Avengers
infinity war and endgame in an interview
with Harper's Bazaar her trainer Erik
Johnson revealed Johansson would often
fast for 12 hours a day sometimes even
longer and moments we pushed beyond that
to 14 to 15 hours depending on the
filming schedule Johnson's build even
more dirt on Johansson's diet to The
Hollywood Reporter claiming Johansson
dropped carbs and the days leading up to
the shoot in order to get some extra
enhancement on her cuts that's just the
kind of ruthlessly sneaky maneuver we've
come to expect from Black Widow isn't it
I adore you
[Music]
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]